good afternoon on this lovely sunny day
here in the uk
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel so i thought i'd go live
today because i have to tell you about
things that have been going on
with the people in and around side trek
that i in and i'm sorry um
hey josh how are you doing
um people in and around mgm that i speak
to
so i told you last week in a very short
video was on the holidays
that michael deluca and pam abdi who are
the uh the chairman of the motion
pictures for mgm and the motion picture
group president basically the two top
people for mgm motion pictures in
particular but they really are the top
two executives have resigned
but
they didn't really as much resign as um
get pushed out
the
mike hopkins who is a big executive for
um amazon released a statement not long
afterwards saying that basically their
departure has paved the way
for mgm to be merged and to become a
part of
amazon and amazon pictures
now this has
really
annoyed
mgm employees that i speak to because
they've been telling me for a long long
time now
um that actually amazon had been making
lots and lots of promises they've been
promising that there would be no job
losses
that there would be um an element of
independent state within within mgm the
mgm would be able to continue to make
its own um business arrangements and
continue to do projects that it wants to
do that basically amazon were just going
to act like a parent company and they
weren't going to interfere too much with
mgm wanted to do
there was repeated memos apparently sent
around mgm from these executives
actually from michael deluca and pam
abdi telling the mgm employees that
amazon just wanted them to carry on
doing their good work the mgm was the
home of some of the world's greatest
storytellers and that's what amazon were
buying
that they were not going to tear mgm
apart
or absorb it into amazon pictures
so what's changed
well
mike hopkins in other statements this
week has blamed the pandemic of course
is blame the pandemic because why
wouldn't you he's basically said that in
2000 when this deal began
they had no clue that we were about to
go through a pandemic that would
basically shut down the entire film
industry for 12 months
and and that's a fair comment none of us
knew that was going to happen obviously
um but it did
that has had a massive financial impact
however
initially amazon and all of the other
streaming services actually did very
well out of the pandemic because we
weren't allowed to go out so we stayed
home we all
booked onto amazon prime
netflix netflix had a massive spike hbo
max in the us had a massive spike
all of these streaming services
disney plus for example really enjoyed
the bump from the fact that none of us
were allowed out
however
in the last six to 12 months they have
that's
plateaued there are no new
well the growth of all of these
streaming services has slowed
significantly and actually amazon again
who had a massive spike in business
early on in the pandemic because we
weren't allowed to go shop so we bought
everything off amazon
stopped and their actual sale price and
their share price has plummeted quite
significantly in the last few months
this is now all being used as an excuse
and why mgm is not going to follow
through with its promises
okay so
why did amazon buy mgm so if you just
quickly talk about that and then i'm
going to explain to you what is actually
going on here because amazon or mgm
isn't quite the company i thought it was
or i'd assumed it was
so
this is going to go back to 1948 now so
but bear with me for a second in 1948
there was a big legal case in the united
states it's called the paramount case
it basically it when it went as high as
the supreme court this was a serious
case
it ordered film studios to stop buying
theaters and cinemas and they had chains
all the big studios had big chains of
theaters
it ordered them to stop doing that
because those chains and theaters that
it owned either it owned or through
deals only showed their movies so mgm
had a series of um these theaters
paramount did disney did and so on and
so on
the supreme court ordered that was
actually against fair play rules and
ordered them to separate
now this impacted mgm significantly
because actually one of the original
owners of mgm was a theater owner he
owned a lot of theaters
they were making 52 films a year
basically releasing a film a week
in california called the city studios in
california
it was as big as anything warner
brothers had or disney and so on and so
on it was a huge site creating lots of
films all at once
1948 this saw a massive impact on that
of their ability to release films in a
in a way that they liked they basically
lost a large part of their um
focus on that area and all of a sudden
there was competition
over the next 10 years and 15 years as
well television became very popular and
everyone started watching tv instead and
that really ended the golden age of
cinema so all of the big studios had a
decision to make
warner brothers actually expanded their
studio lots but they started making tv
shows and they started renting out
studio space
disney double down and they spent a lot
of their money on the disney
world disneyland and created the brand
through that and they also
really heavily invested into television
mgm didn't
mgm sold the culver
um studio
just a second amazon has a spare change
and they want to rule the world
amazon a brand new toy and they want to
play with it all by themselves well i'm
going to get that and get into that in a
second
but they sold culver studios and they
sold a lot of it to real estate they
built a lot of housing and what was left
they sold two sony pictures uh in
68 i think it was sorry
um so so many pictures now own that
studio and it's still sony picture
studios today
mgm took that money and they started the
casino change they built the mgm grand
and things like this and they really
invested heavily in that area
when they then went on in the 80s to
have further financial problems
the studio part of mgm and the um
resort side of mgm got separated they're
now two completely different entities
mgm's um
resort is still owned by the company
that bought them back then mgm studios
and all of the related companies to that
is now owned by
um amazon
this had a massive impact on mgm's
ability and obviously
really was the start of all their
financial problems today
but it's also is relevant to today
because
i always assumed amazon was buying mgm
because of the studios because amazon's
movies doesn't have its own studios it
produces movies through partnerships
with other studios it rents space from
warner brothers it rents space at
pinewood studios and things like this
so i thought it was investing in a
studio company you know an old-fashioned
studio that actually land and actually
somewhere to actually produce films
it's not true they don't
amazon were always very clear that the
main reason they were buying mgm was for
the intellectual properties it's the
stuff mgm owns it's all the movies and
tv shows and things like this it owns
the intellectual rights to those
actual buildings mgmos is very limited
it basically owns its headquarters in um
in california in beverly hills and not a
lot else
i always assumed at very least it owned
the double 07 stage studio at um pangos
studios it doesn't it's only owned it's
only named the double 07 stage because
traditionally that's where the bond
films are made and it was actually built
for the spy who loved me it's one of
europe's one of the world's largest
sound stages
it doesn't even own that and it's got no
rights to it at all disney now actually
rents that sound stage and just
had a big deal with pinewood studios to
take on most of the hello ellie how are
you doing
um to do most of its movies out of there
i mean very proud to be british actually
we make a lot of hollywood blockbusters
in this country
pinewood studios has actually gone on
now to become a multinational company
it's still a private company a private
studio it rents space out to other
studios that make these movies
but this situation occurred because of
i'm gonna get onto stargate in one
minute darker because they are going to
so
the situation is basically that the mgm
as an entity is really virtual
there are no nuts and bolts there are no
buildings
it's people
basically and not many of them
so amazon when they bought mgm they were
just really buying the name they were
just buying the brand now early on they
promised that they were going to invest
in that brand
allow it to expand
stargate is relevant to that because
that was a big part of this three-point
plan that they wanted to run with
bond stargate and then start looking at
the intellectual properties and hoping
to bring back some of those projects
the thing that's going to slow down
stargate coming back now
is that amazon have completely changed
their minds about how to move forward
with mgm and they're going back on all
the things they told the mgm employees
that they were going to do
exactly moving amongst them so they just
wanted the ip
they did lie
or that's how the mgm employees now feel
anyway and the mgm employees and sources
that i speak to they feel like they've
been lighting
and they're now very worried that
actually mgm is an entity is purely
going to be absolved um absorbed into
amazon pictures
that their headquarters will be closed
and so and so on and that actually
michael deluca and pam abdi who were
standing up against this and were
pushing back against amazon and maybe
trying to get them to follow through
some of the promises
were forced out because of this new plan
that they're blaming on the pandemic
for me it basically comes down to
this isn't really going to affect the
stargate's return too much
only in that it's not going to come as
quickly as we thought
the people that were in charge the
people that brad wright has been talking
to the
the project up till now is purely based
within mgm's buildings mgm buildings
that may not be there for much longer
there is a very much a strong feeling
within mgm that they are going to be
dismantled
that amazon amazon pictures are only
interested in the names of the things
they own the intellectual properties
that's all going to be absorbed into
amazon pictures and amazon pictures will
be making those movies
not mgm even though mgm's name might be
on it
so from a stargate point of view this
really puts everything on complete hold
we now have to wait
instead of
just allowing mgm to crack on with
something it had already been working
towards
we're going to have to wait for amazon
to now
go through and restructure mgm
they're going to have to absorbable in
and basically start the process again
that's the problem that we have and that
is the position we're at the moment
mgm employees are furious
apparently michael deluca the important
things is going to be walking and moving
over to warner brothers and apparently
he put feelers out to warner brothers
anything up to a year ago so even when
he was telling mgm employees through
memos not to worry he was already
looking for his way out
and already looking for his next job
so he saw this coming
i always think the people at the top
though they tend to see these things
coming and they're not stupid
so where does that leave us with at the
moment
it's really
what we thought about a year ago
and amazon were telling us all this
stuff but it's really what we feared
when amazon first bought mgm that they
would just tear apart and they would
just use the intellectual properties and
they would just do what they want with
it
but then they told us that that's what
not what they were going to do they
promised that's not what they were going
to do
but they've shown their true colors
for stargate
as i say it just means we're gonna have
to wait a bit longer
and
it really puts it threat whether the
vision of brad wright
is going to be allowed to continue
because that's been done with mgm
that's been planned for and all the work
has been done with mgm the people at the
mgm headquarters in beverly hills
those people may not be in jobs much
longer
so
how amazon decide to do that
i don't know
but the big question is will amazon
bring back stargate
of course they will
they are only interested in the
intellectual properties
after james bond stargate is their most
profitable franchise it is the
most important intellectual property
they own from a financial point of view
and let's be honest these people are
showing us over and over again
that what they're really really
interested
really really interested in is the
teaching and the money
ah
john c there'll be a complete yeah i
think there will be let's let's we're
going to go and have a look at support
some of the comments now please guys
again guys tell me what you think
and there will be a complete play around
management now from top to bottom over
the next year i think it's going to take
over a little i think yeah that's how
it's going to happen amazon didn't need
to do this they could have just funded
mgm they could have allowed mgm which
actually has been reasonably profitable
in the last five years
to crack on and to expand and to have
the people these world-class
storytellers that they kept telling us
about
to do their job and to start telling
something you know to start actually
making something really really
interesting but instead
this is what they're going to do
sci-fi universe i predict when we've
broken up with an anti-trust in 10 years
well it was the antitrust laws that
again i was telling you about earlier
that that forced
um the cinemas to be separated from the
five major studios a few years ago
at the moment amazon compared to
somebody like disney and fox who
obviously they bought fox
is
small fry
um i'm not sure that
amazon are going to be targeted other
than the fact
the government and people like the
federal trade commission aren't
big fans of amazon already
and they've already annoyed
these government things with with their
other practices
but from a entertainment point of view
disney is the company that i think
anti-trust laws will probably be aimed
at over the next 10 years because
they're becoming too big and streaming
services or disney plus is overtaking
almost everybody hbo max is the only one
really that's competing with them at the
moment netflix still has more
subscribers
that's because they've been doing it 10
years
um
they've actually plateaued and are
decreasing and their share prices
decrease significantly so they're also
in trouble
i think amazon will probably about third
on the list for where the government
might go in a few years for antitrust
and antitrust laws might be um a risk of
um so if they do it we're talking at
least a couple of years time to come
about stories look at the positive i
would agree with that um
i think i've said to you more than once
on this channel i'm not 100 convinced by
brad right's vision for this and we know
we haven't seen a lot of it but from the
what he has said i'm not hugely
convinced by it i don't mind if brad
wright takes it back to the drawing
board
he's already apparently rewritten the
script at least once
um it was written three years ago and it
was rewritten about 12 months ago i
think that was after amazon got involved
and basically said look you can think a
lot bigger now
so i don't know if
maybe we're gonna this this might
trigger that it all to be looked at
again um but yeah i would say we're
looking at a couple years
i i think initially
12 months ago they were hoping to have
stargate with our screens by them summer
next year
um i think it'll be more likely this
summer of next the year after
um let's see what else
i can guarantee you google has broken
into trust laws many times uh 100
percent it has
far out let's hope you don't dump right
with a kurzman
entirely truly stuff up any stargate
there has been lots of rumors that they
want to
replace brad right with somebody with
fresh blood they keep saying fresh blood
excuse me
like they did with star trek they
brought in curtin fresh blood
and look at the absolute crap show that
is i've just watched episode nine of
picard i did watch strange new worlds i
actually really like strange newborns
guys i thought it was good
um i'm going to watch the last episode
of picard and apparently that's where
all the stuff happens in the last
episode so we'll see what happens but
generally speaking i hated new star trek
they keep changing things for the sake
of it and i do worry about star game
but if they decide to reimagine the gold
and they do a clean guns on it and they
just bring the you know the gold and
they're just different it'll still look
like the gold will just be like tweaked
you know it's just different
and all the starships and things and
there's the new designs and things you
know i don't i don't want to see it
um
but i think that's possibly what we're
going to be
you know wrestling with is that we're
going to have to put up with the fact
that there's new people in charge and
new ideas of new blood and that they're
going to bring those ideas and they're
going to try and freshen it up and
brad wright said it himself we're going
to have a show for a new generation
i just hope they don't forget us fans
that actually care about canon while
they're doing that
darker than black honestly i wanted to
continue stargate with the wall and
georgia colleges with them are still
able to continue acting i really hope sg
you and sg atlantis guys i've just done
a video about sgu um it'll be out this
week about where those actors are now
could they come back i'm going to be
doing the same for stargate atlantis
picard series two is crap
again like i say um criminal uh i've
looked at all the actors and see where
they are i'll have that video out to you
this week kevin mccabe seou isn't going
to happen brad right startup costs are
huge
um yes but he has also brad wright has
said and joseph mosey has also said that
there will be a conclusion to stargate
universe and stargate atlantis there
will be some sort of end to those
stories
we're not going to get an sgu series and
if you want an sgu series you just just
stop worrying about it it's not going to
happen it would be massively expensive
what we could get is as part of another
series a part of another story
something happens where we maybe could
rescue a couple of people do something
happens basically that we could have we
could find out what happened to sgu
and we'll find out where the atlantis is
and some of that i would like to see
whether something can happen with the
rafe i don't know
but
it won't be an own series what it will
be maybe is as part of a bigger series
we'll get some sort of conclusion and
brad wright and joseph malozy said
that's what they want to do
hopefully new ben will respect canon
possibly learn from primary stuff up
with a new trick
traditionally they don't
they don't
somebody you think about this in like in
work in jobs whenever and i know from my
point whenever i get a new manager
they'll come in and they change things
for the sake of it because they think
they have to put their stamp on it
so stuff just gets changed all the time
um oh we'll do it this way we'll do it
that way because they they're trying to
put their stamp on
what you do and it almost always goes
wrong and almost always goes back to as
it was before
um any new show runner if it's not brad
right we'll do the same thing but to be
honest brad and bright will probably
want to do that because like there's
been a decade but since sc um you've
ended he's gonna want to
freshen it up and change things
shouldn't amazon could have funded mgm
true but they represent competition with
the amazon brand well no they wouldn't
because i mean
to be honest again okay it might be
direct competition with mgm and um
amazon pictures
but that doesn't mean it would be
competition in that respect because they
wouldn't think they wouldn't remove they
wouldn't release movies at the same time
for that because they'd have a parent
company and say well look we've got two
big movies coming out we're not
releasing the same weekend
so that removes that obstacle
and we would always and it would be
absorbed within the amazon family
but big business big companies do have
different
you know brands within their within
their family and they don't necessarily
compete with each other they all do
things that are slightly different
and so they would create projects that
were slightly different um i think you
know i think about like car companies
now sometimes car companies have two or
three different branches like um uh
lexus and toyota and they have so they
have cars that the same but they have a
slightly different perspective on the
ones more luxury one is more economical
or whatever they would do something
similar so they would
have those those brands doing slightly
different sorts of projects so that
they're not in direct competition with
each other
i think over the agents building
stargate
catastrophe for the uh
yeah i would totally agree with that i
would i did a video a few months ago i
really was interested in could we see an
ancient prequel series
it's a prequel series we keep star trek
keeps doing prequel series even if we
don't ask for it they keep doing it um a
stargate would actually be interesting
to do a prequel series and go back to
the ancients so i want to see him
building the gates
um let's see what happens
strangely world started good but towards
the end got stupid well let's see what
happens in the next episode because i
a lot of people are going again very
excited about strange new worlds but i i
wanted to state it picard episode one
was brilliant i was serious two episode
one was really really good i loved it i
loved the stargazer i loved everything
about that episode i got very excited
about it i did a video about it i told
you
episode two not so good three nights and
it went it nose dived off a cliff so
strange new worlds might yeah
what do you think the new enemy should
be and shouldn't be compared to what we
know
um at the moment we we don't necessarily
know there was a competing script that
was going to be something based on the
anunnaki or another and which is an
ancient aliens theory about an alien
race that that conquered the earth once
um i don't think we'll see that i think
we're going to see something that's
quite
homegrownishly and homegrown enemy and
then there'll be
the technological points of stargate
where we left and remember it's been
another 10 years so we're going to
advance another 10 years
we're going to need quite a big bad we
took on the all right and defeated them
we took on the gold and defeated them
we've got we basically defeat the gold
with sticks and shields you know almost
no technology we defeat the gold the
lucian alliance aren't going to be a
threat
i would love to see um like anubis come
back because he's not he's he's died two
or three times he keeps coming back but
i'd love to see that um or i'd love to
see like a merger of two enemies um like
um
the wraith and the gold or something
like that but the gold wold actually
could very easily come back because you
know they're again they're a very
intelligent species
an animal is no more a threat than when
their backs against the wall
you know um an injured animal so there's
lots and lots of things they could do
bringing back something that we've
already seen and then obviously it's
just the imagination of something brand
new but it'd have to be a major threat
maybe something that comes from outside
our galaxy
um i'm telling you bringing kirk back to
the second season strange new worlds
because they're getting ready to reboot
the entire world series and that will be
a good disaster sci-fi universe i said
exactly the same thing a few weeks ago
as soon as i realized that car and the
kirk sorry was coming back for series 2
i might see again why why are they doing
that so soon
um we've already seen from the adverts
for what's going on in strange new
worlds um of pike in the chair with the
bb thing and all this guard and stuff
he's seen his future
are they gonna do another jj abrams and
change that future
they can't surely but for some reason
pike's aware of it
um
kirk coming back into that i think is
massively risky they could get away with
it without peeing all over cannon but
let's be honest they won't because they
don't care
so yeah it's going to be an absolute
nightmare
wesley crusher could not that better not
be a spoiler
i stormy i just told you i haven't seen
the 10th episode yet
if that's a spoiler i'm going to hurt
you
i will fly to america and i will hurt
you if if wesley kushner is in episode
10 of picard series 2
i'm going to kill you
furlings i think is a really good show
i think that's a really good show it's
something that we keep getting told
about and we keep things and there's no
even though they were part of the
species and that they were um you know
um they're they're a good guy where we
think they're a good guy there's i
always think like babylon five with the
vaulons how they were they're supposed
to be the good guys all the way through
and they're supposed to protect us and
then they twisted it at the end
strazinski twisted it and made them a
bad guy i would love to see something
like that with the furlings so they
appear we think they're all good and
nice and then
you know
a marvel thing as well where they are
the bad guys but
they kind of you know it's right sort of
thing what they're trying to do so maybe
they you know they don't obviously copy
immediately uh
a marveling of you know like i'm going
to wipe out half the universe to save
everybody but you know you don't do that
but you could do something that's
you know that they're coming with the
best intentions but those best
intentions are going to why put out
or you know maybe they think humanity's
not ready for space travel so they
decide we're not allowed anymore or
something like that but um i'd love to
see
the specifics i i'm seriously stormy
seriously if you've ruined that for me
um
currently they're being told
that it's not going to be
not going to be a um
a reboot it's not going to be a hard
reboot it will be a soft reboot in this
new actors new thing even though a
couple of actors might come back but
it's not going to be a hard reboot but
that only depends on whether brad wright
stays in charge if he doesn't
then anything's
that that's my problem with this news
really that all of a sudden anything is
on the cards again
we were pretty sure we knew what was
going to happen
now we've no clue
because this is all getting
put back to the drawing board again um
uh i just i don't know to see what
happens
benjamin i'm i mean two minds about the
post disclosure earth with stargate and
that's what brad wright said he wants to
do
and i'm two two minds about it on one
hand i think it's the only thing that
makes sense
of course it would have to be you know
known to the world there because it
doesn't make sense for it to still be a
secret but in the other hand
that makes it a lot more like star trek
all of a sudden everybody knows we've
got spaceships flying around it's not
secret the whole point of stargate and
what feelers target was that it could
actually be happening in the world
um under cheyenne mountain there could
really be a stargate command um
and
if if they do a post-disclosure world
they've just got to do it really really
carefully so that they don't go silly
with it basically and like i say i want
stargate not star trek
star getting used to five an original
gold but mutated so they look cooler
una yeah yeah massive healing abilities
yeah
they could find something that's related
to the gold world that's different and
that's why they're different so we get
we get them i think because same time i
don't just want them to remake stargate
i don't just want a new
stargate atlantis was different from
stargate sg1 stargate sgu is different
from stargate alliances purposefully
because you do want something a bit
different you just catch 22 isn't it if
they just do the same thing and don't
change anything it's boring
but if so we're going to demand
something new but at the same time we're
going to say do not change too much so
it's a catch 22 for him they've got to
change something
um
from what i'm hearing
you've had some offers to buy star trek
power man
they can't sell it because of kurtzman
i think they wouldn't they wouldn't have
a bomb
welcome to twitch
thank you i should have mentioned by the
way that we are actually transmitting on
twitch today
for the first time ever
so if you're not on twitch um there is
should be a link on the community page
i'll add it onto the facebook page as
well so please go and join there um it's
just another platform i don't know how
it works but my son told me i've got to
be on twitch
we're on twitch
i hope your inside personal studio
doesn't leave due to the changes um
though
i've got four or five i've actually five
people now i speak to that work in and
around mgm and three of them are
direct employees one of them is quite a
menial job he he hears a lot of what
goes on because he's one of these people
is in and around lots of different bits
but he's just he's quite he's not he's
not a skilled worker so he'll go work
anywhere he's not bothered um
the other two are actual creative people
so they are bothered
um but they'll go and work for i imagine
that this would be absorbed into amazon
studios um but no none of them are
talking about leaving as far as i know
but i know one person i speak to that
works with a company that isn't mgm is
linked to mgm
is looking because he's worried that if
mgm cuts their contracts and it all
shifts to amazon their company will just
because the bulk of their work is mgm
let's have a look what else is in there
kids under contracts 2026 that is 100
correct dax hello sir
um
yes amazon prime uh here in the uk
mgm already has a streaming service on
amazon it costs five pound a month a
load of mgm movies are on there um and
some tv series
um stargate was on there
um until recently and they took it off
sg-1 you can only get through amazon
private in the uk anyway um by paying
for the series but it's all on sky for
us so it doesn't matter too much but
yeah i think mgm will
they will really push that um as an
element of thing
the problem with amazon prime's got is
disney plus
disney plus have come in
and for less money than amazon prime
they have
one channel
they will put moves on there and
actually ask you to pay a bit more but
generally speaking the movies go on
there for free almost immediately while
free you pay the subscription but within
the normal channel fox is within it
everything is under that umbrella of
disney plus so you've got a lot of
entertainment there
amazon prime of trying to do it by
creating little add-ons so you pay for
amazon prime but then you pay for mgm
then you pay for stars then you pay for
something else and there's actually
loads of channels in amazon prime
they're not going to be able to keep
doing that and people will get pissed
off with it basically because
they can go to disney and there's loads
on disney plus you can watch new stuff
every day so they're not going to be
able to keep doing it the way they're
doing at the moment
i didn't know that
i didn't know twitch is owned by amazon
ah i am a chill i'm being paid from
i got i got used to calling shil a lot
disney has hulu
isn't hulu more of um
i don't really watch hulu i don't think
we have that in the uk anyway guys that
is the news
that's where we're at
just to recap really quickly the mgm
employees and contacts i talk to are
furious they're worried for their jobs
they genuinely believe that mgm is going
to be as it exists at the moment
dissolved and just absorbed into amazon
um and amazon mike hopkins the chief
executive at amazon studios just
basically said exactly the same thing he
has said that michael deluca and pam
abdi leaving
paves the way for mgm to absorb into
amazon prime and amazon movies
so
for stargate that very clearly means
we're not going to get stargate as
quickly as we thought we might
um
and that is a massive
massive shame because i want this show
on my screens now i want a movie i want
series i want
i i want what i consider to be the
biggest sci-fi franchise and not on our
screens today back
it should be back it could be easily as
big as star trek as far as i'm concerned
it could be
the show that the sci-fi show that is
the jewel in the crown for prime and
amazon if they really want it to be
so let's hope they crack on so if you
are new to the channel please like
subscribe if you are going to twitch
amazon um
get on there and and follow us on there
as well i'll be streaming all of these
videos on there as well from now on
you can become a fully-fledged side
tracker please consider hitting the join
button
and in the meantime guys please everyone
stay safe
enjoy the sun it's come out for us here
in the uk cloud it over a little bit
i'm gonna go have a barbecue with my
family
um really please
guys stay safe and i'll see you all
really really soon
i have to do the outro
which is
[Music]
you